Donald Trump frequently asserts that he
destroyed Isis that of course the
decision he made to pull US troops from
northern Syria was a good one despite
concerns from actual foreign policy
experts and generals that Isis would
immediately re-enter and that it would
be disastrous for the Kurds and case in
point we are now learning that Isis has
started to quote reassert itself what a
nice word in both Iraq and Syria they
have a new leader a former genocide er
of the Yazidi people this was based on a
report submitted to the United Nations
Security Council and it says that ISIL
as they know it after losing a bunch of
territory physical territory has started
to reassert itself in the Syrian Arab
Republic and in Iraq they're doing more
insurgent attacks they are calling and
planning for breaking out Isis fighters
from detention facilities exploiting
weaknesses in the security environments
of both countries adding quote the
borders between Iraq and the Syrian Arab
Republic remain inadequately secured
this report was based on information
from a bunch of different UN member
states and it shows that a lot of those
states are assessing that the new leader
of Isis is a mere mohammed syed abdul
rahman al mal wa al Maleh i hope i
pronounced that correctly so there's
really nothing surprising here and to be
clear this doesn't mean that the United
States needs to be involved forever this
doesn't mean the United States has a
responsibility or a right to be the
world's police it does confirm the
absolutely aimless and Confused nature
of Donald Trump's policy though he brags
about taking out the leader Abu Bakr al
Baghdadi died in October but the reality
is a new leader just comes in and in
this case the new leader was literally
the second-in-command to Abu Bakr al
Baghdadi Donald Trump insists that
everything is all set he regularly says
things at rallies like this which was
back in 2019 thanks to the global
coalition including all of you here
today and to our other partners the Isis
Caliphate has been decimated
nobody thought it was possible to do it
this quickly three weeks ago I was in
Iraq and I was talking to some of our
great generals and I gave them the
absolute go-ahead
I said go at it how long it will it take
once you get started you said sir one
week Trump claims endless victories then
and now and all the time and yet the
actual reports from real people who
understand things confirm that Isis is
surging as was predicted would happen
that Isis is reasserting now the
questions about US foreign policy are
far more complex just because we could
predict that what Donald Trump was doing
was going to lead to a resurgence of
Isis which I've been telling you about
for a year at this point or longer is it
the responsibility of the United States
to destroy Isis I don't know I mean on
the one hand we can't be the world's
police we can't just be constantly
militarily in endless numbers of
countries for indefinite periods of time
on the other hand Isis grew in part
because of a vacuum that was created by
our own foreign policy decisions so
aside from a general philosophy of
interventionism
versus non-interventionism there are
real questions when we are part of
creating a problem and remember that
taking away territory and killing
leaders does not root out the ideology
which is much more difficult to fight in
something we've spoken to experts about
on the program so this is admittedly
complicated stuff it goes well beyond
the capability and knowledge of Donald
Trump but to add to a complicated
situation a clueless and arrogant
president is very much the last thing
that we need so the headline despite
Trump's claim that it's all over we've
defeated Isis we got this leader we got
that Lee whatever Isis is growing once
again they are reasserting themselves
they reportedly have 100 million u.s.
dollars in their reserves and the
ideology most importantly is very much
alive and well do you feel like you just
don't have enough time to become as
intellectually well-rounded as you would
like to be that they're just
enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about 8 bucks a month
but you can try it for free for a week
and get 25% off a subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work i've
just finished listening to upheaval by
Jared Diamond Jared Diamond a tremendous
author whose work I've previously
recommended excellent book looking at
some of modern history's biggest
national crises to figure out how
different countries ended up in such
precarious situations Blinky's has
totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for blankets they
have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent then blink astiz for
you